wir schauen zurück nach deutschland
meine damen und herren was ist nun also
der korona plan für weihnachten nach all
dem hin und her und dem chaos soll das
heute vormittag endlich geklärt werden
ab 11 uhr sitzen die länderchefs mit
noch kanzlerin merkel und bald kanzler
scholz zusammen um 13 uhr dann die
ergebnisse wir berichten in einem bild
live spezial ja und dann soll es auch
endlich beschlüsse geben die man länger
als eine woche halten in welche richtung
es geht können wir ihnen jetzt schon
sagen denn bild live liegt die
beschlussvorlage vor wir haben hier das
papier was thomas der hand hält über das
der korona gipfel heute nachmittag berät
und wir wollen jetzt schon einmal über
die wichtigsten punkte sprechen die wir
hier in einer grafik zusammengefasst
haben und zwar sollen restaurants
theater und kino nur für geimpfte und
genießen öffnen der einzelhandel soll
nur noch mit 2g
dreht war sein außer natürlich
supermärkte die man dann eben für den
täglichen gebrauch braucht maximal
10.000 personen sollen auf
großveranstaltungen erlaubt sein und die
impfpflicht kommt erst für pfleger und
dann für alle darüber wollen wir jetzt
auch mal sprechen mit unserem
politikchef reporter peter tiede der
hier im studio ist und wir haben noch
drei weitere corona pläne hier die in
diesen beschluss vorliegen einmal neun
monate nach der impfung soll der
impfstatus verfallen apotheker und
zahnärzte dürfen impfen und die masken
pflicht soll in allen schulen weiterhin
gängen es ist noch kein beschluss muss
man dazu sagen sondern ein entwurf für
den beschluss peter da sind noch einige
eckige klammern dabei da kann sich also
noch etwas ändern trotzdem das ist die
große linie auf jeden fall auf die man
sich verständigen wird ab 11 uhr wie
gesagt sitzt man zusammen und um 13 uhr
soll dann in einer pressekonferenz das
ergebnis verkündet werden wir berichten
live in einem spezial deiner anordnung
der lockdown für ungeimpfte ist da das
ist klipp und klar so die kommen außer
zu edeka lidl und wie die anderen
supermärkte heißen und zu kostbar und so
roßmann kommen sie ins meer ein das ist
völlig klar überall nur noch 2 g die
länder können nur noch 2 g + draufsetzen
also geimpft genießen und getestet
sogar noch drauf also da aber nicht mehr
nur getestete sondern muss genießen
geimpft und dann noch mal dann noch mal
getestet sein und gucken wir mal auf
wenn wir aufs weihnachtsfest gucken was
das für ungeimpfte heißt also wer nicht
geimpft ist oder wir überhaupt nur einen
in der familie hat vor einer ungewissen
da kann nur noch der eigene haushalt
plus zwei personen kinder unter 14
jahren zählen da nicht mit aber das ist
dann die beengte weihnacht also wer sich
nicht impfen lässt hat kleine
weihnachtsfeier so das ist das im großen
ganzen und dann muss man noch dazu
nehmen das sind bundes bundesweit
einheitliche standards und natürlich
kommt in die impfpflicht das ist so klar
wie das amen in der kirche wir haben
jetzt die impfpflicht die für die
übernächste woche abgestimmt werden das
könnte in der nächsten woche sein also
sagen wir so es heißt noch vor
weihnachten soll das beraten werden erst
der zweite dritte lesung kann man wenn
man will auch in einer woche hinkriegen
da kann man eine fristverkürzung machen
dann geht das gesetzlich dann kommt man
in einer woche durch den bundestag durch
freitag tagt dann der bundesrat damals
wären auch durch und dann werde ihre
pflicht im prinzip im februar oder so
was von da her also die für die
altenheime und für pflegeheime und für
kliniken die könnte vor weihnachten
kommen die kann noch zum jahresende
kommen die komplette impfpflicht die
könnte dann wenn der bundestag
rechtzeitig fertig ist ansonsten
gruppenantrag geben da wird dann auch
die gewissens freigabe dann erteilt oder
können denn jeder abgeordnete abstimmen
wie er will da gibt's keinen
fraktionszwang und die könnte dann ende
februar anfang oder ende märz kommen
dass wir die totale im fliegt wobei man
bei der totalen pflicht dazu sagen muss
das ist eine pflicht eingeführt die wird
auch sanktioniert mit bußgeldern aber
durchgesetzt werden kann sich faktisch
gar nicht also zwangsimpfung wird es so
nicht geben ins gefängnis muss auch
keiner gehen dabei die leute die beim
existenzminimum leben wenn die ihre
muskeln nicht bezahlen dann wird das
gehalt gepfändet thema impfpflicht lange
wurde er eben darüber diskutiert jetzt
wird sie also kommen der wind hat sich
gedreht von total gegen die impfpflicht
zu total für die impfpflicht
impfpflicht
sicher falsch und impfpflicht ist in
deutschland nicht möglich und weil es ja
schon wieder anders behauptet wird auch
in den sozialen medien ich gebe ihnen
mein wort ich gebe ihnen mein wort es
wird in dieser plant keine impfpflicht
jedem hören sie endlich auf anderes zu
behaupten ich finde es wäre falsch wenn
jetzt eine debatte beginnt über die
pflichten und ähnliches thema was schert
mich mein geschwätz von gestern das hat
schon konrad adenauer gesagt jetzt
klingt das so bei olaf scholz im bild
interview
da wo menschen ganz besonders geschützt
werden müssen den
altenpflegeeinrichtungen krankenhäuser
müssen die beschäftigten sich impfen
lassen und gleichzeitig brauchen wir für
einen zeitpunkt im nächsten jahr das
kann man von februar das kann anfang
märz an die aussage bis dahin sollten
sich aber alle geimpft haben denn meine
idee mein vorschlag ist ja dass der
zeitpunkt bis zu dem dann jeder und jede
sich hat impfen lassen auch nicht allzu
fern liegt also mein vorschlag anfang
februar oder anfang märz wieder
erklären sondern mal wie kam es jetzt zu
dieser wende bei den politikern man hat
gehofft wir gehen es mal wirklich mal
von der gnädigen variante aus man hat
gehofft dass man die impfquote so
hinkriegt dass sie genügend leute
einfach impfen lassen dass genügend
leute aus unserer sicht so vernünftig
sind dass sie zum arzt gehen und sich
die spritze geben lassen einmal und auch
zweimal und blieb auch dreimal das hat
nicht geklappt und jetzt steht man vor
der situation dass man sehen dass man
sieht dass die katastrophe auf uns
zurollt und man kann jetzt
verfassungsrechtlich vorher was
verfassungsrechtlich auch nicht möglich
gewesen jetzt ist es was uns rechtlich
möglich wenn du alles mögliche angeboten
also die ersten punkt angeboten hat die
zweite impfung angeboten hat und die
dritten impfung angeboten wird wenn eine
große kampagne gefahren hast dann kannst
du als staat sagen jetzt müssen wir eine
impfpflicht machen man fängt mit der
sektoralen impfpflicht an weil auch die
muss vor der totalen pflicht stehen muss
vor der allgemeinen pflicht stehen du
musst als staat alles mögliche versucht
um die muss kein anderes mittel kein
anderes geeignetes mittel mehr zur
verfügung stehen also das was du machst
als staat an einer verhältnismäßig sein
und es ist dann nur verhältnismäßig wenn
alle anderen mittel versagt haben und
das ist aus sicht von
verfassungsrechtlern jetzt der fall es
gibt ja auch da ein streit also ex
innenminister otto schily von der spd
sich gemeldet und sagt das ist
verfassungswidrig wie er mit
verfassungsrechtlern gesprochen die
sagen das ist verfassungsrechtlich
möglich schränkt aber ein die
zwangsvorführung für eine impfung die
ist da nicht möglich also man hat erst
alles versucht es an das hinzukriegen
das hat nicht geklappt und dann musste
man halt wortbrüchig werden wir sind
gespannt was christian lindner der
künftige finanzminister auch dazu sagen
wird gerade die fdp die sich ja immer
für die freiheit und gegen eine pflicht
oder hans wann eingesetzt hat er wird
gleich bei uns im studio sein und
natürlich werden wir ihnen auch danach
fragen aber wir haben auch die menschen
auf der straße gefragt was denken sie
impfpflicht ja oder nein
ich bin für die impfpflicht weil ich
finde dass es
normal ist dass wir zu solchen zeiten
alle als gemeinschaft zusammenhalten was
jetzt die politik macht ihr mit die
impfpflicht was er einführen wollen bin
ich nicht direkt einverstanden ist soll
jedoch über sein eigenes leben ich bin
gegen eine gesetzliche pflicht weil
zwänge sind niemals gut ich bin gegen
eine gesetzliche pflicht weil ich der
meinung wenn jeder sollte über seinen
körper selber verfügen und das mit sich
selber abmachen ich bin generell gegen
alles was pflicht ist also man kann auch
die kühe nehmen und man kann es
vielleicht auch so sagen dass man darum
bittet jetzt im moment bei der aktuellen
situation aber mit gewalt hat noch nie
etwas geklappt ich bin gegen eine
impfpflicht weil ich finde dass freiheit
das wichtigste ist also ich befürworte
die pflicht also nicht unbedingt weil
sie keinen hundertprozentigen schutz
bietet und weil es nicht meiner ansicht
nach die nach den langfristigen
auswirkungen noch nicht erforscht sind
ich bin aber dann dafür dass man
konsequent ist und dann auch keinen
klinik platz in anspruch nimmt wenn man
dann tatsächlich
angesicht ansteckt ich bin gegen die
impfpflicht das soll jeder halten wie er
will und jedoch so ist ein eigenes
risiko haben oder nicht ich bin auch
eigentlich schon aus solidaritäts
gründen dafür dass man dann wieder ein
halbwegs vernünftiges leben
führen kann für eine impfpflicht war
will keine toten mehr haben das ist für
mich der wichtigste grund zu sagen
impfpflicht ja auf jeden fall
und wenn jemand gegen die impfpflicht
ist denn würde ich echt dazu verdonnern
mal auf so eine intensivstation zu gehen
und dort mal zu schauen wie es dort
aussieht und wie es der pflegekräfte
geht ich glaube damit ist eigentlich
alles gesagt was für eine impfpflicht
spricht ja also die nation ist gespalten
täter wir haben viele weihnachtsmärkte
im hintergrund dort auch gesehen was ist
mit denen die werden nicht verboten auch
der weihnachtsmarkt sperre für nicht
geimpfte wer geimpft ist also die
bundesländer können selber entscheiden
und die stete ob sie weihnachtsmarkt
machen ja oder nein wenn sie machen zwei
gehen das ist pflicht sie können aber
auch sagen zweig also geimpfte und
genießen die sich dann zusätzlich testen
lassen müssen das ist ihnen freigestellt
also es gibt kein generelles
weihnachtsmarkt verbot wir haben jetzt
schon so eine skurrile situation also
potsdam die landeshauptstadt brandenburg
hat den weihnachtsmarkt geschlossen zwar
die potsdamer nach berlin um
weihnachtsmarkt so gut ist also
weihnachtsmarkt wird es weiter geben
können so wir werden mit christian
lindner darüber sprechen sind sehr
gespannt darauf